all right I think I think I'm live is
this thing on
I don't know what I'm doing is people
like to point out on on twitch so from
last time I changed the delay a little
bit I had a delay between my mic and my
video last time and I made like a
hundred millisecond adjustment tell me
if that seems synced up now let me see
where my settings are yeah I've got a
hundred millisecond offset right now and
I don't know if that's enough if not I
can just change it sync is great synched
it's perfect all right so maybe it was
that hundred milliseconds if it becomes
unsynched let me know I've got a bunch
of stuff planned for today let me see
I've got my laundry list here and then I
also have my list of things to talk
about in addition to just the laundry
I'm gonna do people have been asking me
is that there gonna be a set twitch
schedule not really I mean one thing
I've been testing out is premiering each
day's episode on twitch around 4:30
which is before we even publish that to
YouTube so it's sort of like new first
on Twitch and then just seeing the
number of followers and twitch prime
subscribers that come up so that's thing
we're that's something we're doing SB TV
is rating with a party of 23 I think
this is the first time I've been rated
to be perfectly frank and people are
saying I should drink rate other people
I will some people are saying that the
sync is not perfect that's interesting
let me see if I can just change it I
don't know if this change is live but
what if I change to 200 millisecond
offset I changed it to 200 milliseconds
it looks a little closer on my end I
don't know if anything changed with you
guys but let me know I'm 50 milliseconds
off okay then let me go back to 150 and
see if that helps
oh other people saying that it's fine
and it was fine before there are people
saying that it's fine with zero 100 150
and 200 milliseconds so that that's sort
of Oh 200 looked better
it's only off if you play ik let's stick
with 150 for now and then I'm not gonna
mess with it during the stream people
can let me know after so anyway I don't
know if there's gonna be a twitch
schedule I mean my approach is I'll just
announce on my regular show when I'm
going to be streaming and so like Monday
Tuesday Wednesday I announced today at
6:30 p.m. I'd be streaming and now I'm
streaming and we'll just see what does
well and see what people are interested
in and we'll just sort of go from there
okay I got that emotes people asking
about emotes as of this morning they
were still pending and this is day seven
of the emotes pending and now the other
still pending my contacts at twitch are
saying it should be done this week so
that's that I saw a little bit of Burnie
on Joe Rogan yeah I'm I don't know about
talking to destiny right now I mean it
seems like he's got his own thing going
I don't know that he wants to talk to me
about that right now the emotes are
we've got one that is called ideas which
is sort of a reference to the Battle of
ideas we've got one that's like a
pac-man video game thing we've got an
emote that's me with my crazy hair from
the day I did that thing there's like a
sad David one we have a producer Pat
--mode and we have a former producer
lewis emote that are at tears two and
three so that stuff I don't know I'm
hoping it'll be live by the end of the
week and then we'll just sort of see it
could be because it's so many that it's
taking a while yeah maybe but the thing
is you'd think they'd still be able to
do review them one one at a time
I am new on Twitch for people asking
I've only got 9,000 followers on Twitch
and what's fascinating about twitch and
I have a bunch of stuff to get to by the
way which I will get to in a moment and
I'll even put up some of it for people
to see what we are gonna be looking at
eventually I am new to twitch what's
incredible about Twitch's so on YouTube
as you can see here I have seven hundred
and thirteen thousand subscribers on
YouTube those are equivalent to
followers on Twitch I only have like
nine thousand followers on Twitch but
the percentage of people that are
contributing to the twitch channel is
crazy
as a percentage compared to YouTube on
YouTube I estimate that like 1/3 of 1%
of my followers are have either super
chatted or our YouTube subscribers or
have signed up on my website we have
like a nearly a 12% contributor rate on
twitch meaning like of the 9,000
followers around 12% of them have either
become subscribers or cheered or
whatever which is just like insane I
mean I don't want to be extrapolating
out too much but if that continues then
I mean you know that's gonna be a really
good thing let me thank a few people
Jemaine Clement thanks for the twitch
Prime subscription slam CAD has signed
up with twitch Prime Dan of Earth is a
tier 1 subscriber thank you done don t
or Donte ax TV twitch prime subscriber
thank you so much West Coast weed has
subscribed with twitch prime meta Lingus
man twitch Prime subscription the hoop
god twitch prime subscriber social scrub
has subscribed with twitch prime Green
Man 137 has cheered four bits which I
really appreciate
wild Hufflepuff has subscribed with
twitch Prime and flibberty flab has
cheered 107 bits which I really
appreciate so here's my goal for today
last last stream which was Sunday
evening I had a goal up there of 25 new
website members that's like our primary
funding source that's like the main way
that my program is funded and we fell
short I think we only had like seven of
25 and I really want to open the phone
lines today at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 I have
it ready to go at any time I have the
power to open the phone lines they are
not open right now so I've reduced the
new member target to just 15 and I will
thank everybody who signs up and in fact
we already have a few people to thank
I want to thank Tyler Valadez who is new
member number one of the evening and
Phillip Marshall who's new member number
two so let me update that on screen
right now we are at 2 of 15 I would love
to open the phone line so please
consider grabbing a membership I don't
care if it's discounted or not
it all counts okay let me get to some of
the things I wanted to talk about let me
thank a couple other people calamity
badger is a tier 1 subscriber I
appreciate that
norge PAB or gnorga PAB has cheered a
hundred bits pappy mcpeepers has cheered
one bit and Alan Roberson has cheered a
thousand bits and subscribed with twitch
prime that Rockets Alan Roberson - oh
that's weird the all-time top cheers
haven't been updated oh I guess he s
Alan Robertson is like tied for seven
through something with a thousand turkey
bacon and cheese still the all-time top
cheer with 6,500 and still the all-time
top gift er of subscriptions as well
okay so let me tell you about so a bunch
of good stuff has been going on this
week one thing is we YouTube has been
crazy and part of the reason I'm even on
twitch has have been the YouTube
problems that I've been having hold on
Anthony Fantana is sending me a message
oh right okay I'm gonna be doing
something with Fantana soon and we're
trying to coordinate some stuff he's
gonna be in Boston actually doing a show
which everybody should go to I will be
away for I'm gonna be traveling then but
otherwise I would absolutely be there so
you YouTube has been a problem lately
but at the same time the channel is kind
of on fire all of a sudden we've got
seven hundred and thirteen thousand
subscribers we're on track to hit a
million subscribers in under a year I
think we're like ten and a half months
away if we can keep the current sort of
path going which would be amazing and my
goal is to get twitch to be a quarter
the size of YouTube like this that sound
like a crazy goal oh four users asking
for lower video quality options that is
not up to me what I've been told is that
partners get priority with transcoding
to lower resolutions and that if there's
bandwidth twitch bandwidth that
affiliates sometimes will get options
for lower resolution but I'm told that
there's nothing
can do about that if that's different
that's wrong then please let me know
because I will have been misinformed if
that's the case but as far as I know I
can't do anything about that my goal is
to get twitch to 25% of YouTube ok so
right now seven hundred and thirteen
thousand YouTube subscribers that means
a quarter would be roughly a hundred and
seventy-five thousand twitch followers
so that's like my immediate goal if
YouTube grows I am going to keep the
twitch goal at twenty five percent I
don't know if that strikes people is
crazy let me know if it strikes you as
crazy anybody is that crazy partners get
transcode always yes and my
understanding is correct there there are
well-meaning myths misinformed people in
twitch do I don't know that I want a
partner kimchi because if you partner
with twitch I think you're not allowed
to stream anywhere else and I want to be
doing that I can stream at a lower
bitrate okay that's fair I'm using
stream labs OBS and I just left the
default settings so that maybe that may
be something I can do it's not crazy it
could be done to get twitch to 25% of of
YouTube okay good alright and I should
post a short video on YouTube before
going live on Twitch yeah I mean the
thing about that is YouTube technically
does not allow primarily using the
platform to promote other platforms and
I want to be careful about that it'll be
months before I get half of that yeah
that's fine I mean this is it so it's a
long term thing but that's that's the
immediate goal so anyway my point that
I'm trying to get to is it has been a
really really good week on YouTube
actually and I think some of it has been
story selection let me just refresh this
oh and these numbers are delayed but
we've had like a bunch of clips get a
hundred thousand views or close to it my
moscow Mitch clips started slow and
ended up it's all close to a hundred
thousand the stock market clip is at 111
Trump triggered is at 230 which is
awesome
Trump destroy stock market with tariffs
is at 100 Fox interrupts immigrant is at
143 so it's been a solid solid week and
then these numbers are actually delayed
some of these are way beyond like the
[ __ ]
repeats shooters manifesto verbatim clip
which says 25 that's weird I wonder why
the numbers are so delayed if I look at
real-time it is at 35 so in any way any
case it's been a really solid week on
YouTube and I think we're just getting
better at figuring out the right
publishing schedule and a bunch of
different a bunch of different things
there so that's that's exciting stuff
let me tell you about some of the
stories I'm going to be covering
tomorrow on the show which I've been
prepping recently but let me thank some
people who have signed up our Huffman
thanks for the twitch Prime subscription
octo lakhs really appreciate the twitch
Prime subscription origins and tall
tales cheering for bits and then almost
immediately cheering another hundred
bits which makes it a hundred and two
which I really really appreciate evil
mr. muffinz says how do your hundred
thousand view videos get so much more
exposure than the lower view ones it's
just a matter of like what catches at
the right time oh it's just a
combination of stuff and the things that
we published earlier in the day tend to
do better because there's just more
people that are awake and I don't know I
mean it's it's hit or miss did I see the
destiny Michael Brooks debate I did not
I don't know anything about that social
blade is getting impressive yeah I never
really look at social blade because it's
just like it just almost nothing on
there seems accurate you can click the
smile face in the chat box I don't know
if that's to me or to someone else
destiny is free to chat right now okay I
mean if destiny
I guess if destiny wants to do something
I wasn't really planning on it I was I
was hoping to take phone calls from
people in the audience let me see who
else I should I've got to thank other
people here because people are signing
up where is this okay Jesse vanwie is
the newest david pakman show member on
the website so that gets us to 3 of 15
the goal is 15 website members and I'll
open the phones I've never opened up the
on Twitch other than on the debate
nights and the debate nights were you
know a whole a whole other thing
play chess against destiny yeah I don't
know about any of it I'm not really set
up for that let me just see here if I
can
I'm guessing destiny would want to talk
on discord let me see I just don't know
what I mean I guess it'd be good for my
stream to do something with destiny let
me see here
destiny yesterday I mean are you I don't
want to bug him if he's not actually
interested in doing something with me I
don't know if people are actually
telling the truth about that I don't
even know I'm just not really set up for
that just just bug him please he's sad
over the Brooks debate would I consider
debating destiny let me see here I'll
send him a message and just see what's
going on
just need to figure out how I just need
to figure out how discord works let me
go home okay let's see hey did you want
to connect oh he just sent me a message
did you want to connect people are
demanding it
something about TPP and Michael Brooks
this is we I'm not usually in this
milieu but now that I I'm here I guess I
should consider doing something but
destiny he does send me subscribers oh
joy and call okay let me see oh you know
what I don't even have headphones on
hold on a second
let me see here hey hold on a second I
don't even I've had phones on and can't
hold on can you hear me hello yeah I can
hear you okay I mean I can't hold on at
all
oh you can't hold on okay I'm just hold
on I'm just plugging headphones in cuz
things are I don't even know what it
seems like something got crazy on your
channel today hold on yeah let's see
here and got that turn down the volume a
little bit all right
can you hear me okay I can hear you just
fine okay so like what happened people
are saying you got to talk to destiny
Sagat did you see something about
michael brooks and you're sad tonight i
a little hold on before we have this
conversation yeah okay click this hold
on a second click this leech s bullet oh
no I don't play 30 second chance
what are you scared Hackman all right
let me see hold on let me just pull it
up okay I mean let's let's just see
I hope this type of stuff generates
subscribers on Twitch cuz otherwise this
stuff is like a huge waste of time it's
not a waste of time this is important
okay this is an intellectual boxing
right now to see where we stand on the
issues are you ready yeah is this you
I'm playing anonymous oh yeah this is me
okay all right
[Music]
I've never played this format before
that's unfortunate for you because this
is this is the format that I excel on
okay
[Music]
this is getting crazy here okay I've
never played this format and I just I
guess I just got crushed okay I wanted
to do all right now that were now that
we're through this important important
trust game oh what's up
oh I'm sorry I had a conversation with
Michael Brooks today cuz he wanted to I
so I've been giving okay I don't know
how familiar with my stuff but basically
I've had a problem with what I
considered to be oh my god militant as
[ __ ] progressives online I hate him I
hate him I hate all these commies and
socialists kids the chapo traphouse are
is the on ironic like Marxist and stuff
they're just annoying to me I don't
necessarily hate their ideology they
just come at me with a whole bunch of
bunk arguments 95% of these people don't
even know like labor value theory like
they have no idea they're talking about
but they're so quick to throw out every
single like contemporary understanding
of economics to make some argument for
some crazy socialist fantasy world where
everything is free nobody has to work no
other countries mess with us although
every prong is just it's been
frustrating me so any time these people
and I give certain arguments people say
like oh well he's Dave Rubin
oh he's conservative now oh he's all
right oh he's extreme right-wing it's
like okay dudes so I guess Michael
Brooks kind of like caught wind of this
like Twitter war we have a whole bunch
of Mutual's and people are poking like
oh go school destiny on some topic we
talked for a little bit and I somehow I
guess he chooses a topic of the TPP and
I'm like okay fine the TPP is probably a
good place for us to start because
there's a lot of like I guess neoliberal
or whatever policies revolving trade and
economics and maybe we can hammer some
these out yeah and he came on and he
basically talked to me for like 55
minutes and I couldn't get a single why
him oh are you serious like you barely
said anything how many were to go
through and tally the time if I had to
make a legitimate guess I would say I
probably like in the last 30 minutes I
probably spoke for three or four minutes
and I think he spoke for like 26 or 27
minutes now why do why didn't you
interject and say like hey listen it's
not really
conversation unless I get a chance to
talk to well cuz I tried to but like
every time I did he had like a defusing
so like he would say like hold on hold
on this is really important yeah and he
would like do that and everything okay
and then he would like but then any time
I tried to address like so he would ring
up like 10 points and I try to go back
and ring up the first one and then as
soon as I would get like halfway through
addressing it he would launch off into a
whole other very important monologue it
is like so did you feel like anything
was accomplished I mean the first part
of the conversation was like a fun
little circle jerk where we seem to
agree in terms of like people being
crazy on social media and [ __ ] but huh
okay well that I mean listen I don't I
didn't see that but I've been dealing
with just you know I mean there's like
III guess my thing my big thing that I
don't like doing this thing where I just
like criticize the left from the left
for clicks I think that there's
legitimate stuff to criticize the left
for and one of those things is just like
the narcissism of small differences it's
as it's called we're like we agree on
95% of stuff and we make the focus the
5% we disagree on to it to the point
where we end up just like losing and and
it's completely counterproductive and I
think some of the stuff you're talking
about is under that umbrella uh-huh
what do you I'm curious what do you
think in general do you have you read
even much into the TPP do you have a
strong opinion on it err well listen I
mean
so since it died I stopped following it
altogether but my basic view was like I
can find certain things in it that would
arguably be like incremental
improvements over what we have now but
like I just have a real problem with and
I know that these exist outside of the
TPP framework but I think corporations
have too much power and they exist
outside of the judicial system already
too much so you know that mechanism that
the TPP included that multinationals
could basically you know be an
arbitration outside of the laws of any
individual country is sort of that like
I saw a little bit of Bernie on Rogan
yesterday and when Rogan asked him like
why is this stuff legal and Rogan said
well because they made the laws I just
have a huge problem with that but that
doesn't merely you know I mean like this
is one way to look at it but it has to
be that way right like I would never if
I'm accusing a country of making unfair
practices that are making my firm
uncompetitive I don't want their that
country's courts to determine whether I
would or lose my case
like there's a reason why people always
resort to this third-party arbitration
in so in thousands of other bilateral
trade agreements and other trade
agreements around the world a lot of
moocher America is already a part here
like I don't want to sue a company in
Canada or even the Government of Canada
because I think that they're
implementing some unfair labor practice
it's [ __ ] just my firm over and then
their courts decide who wins it loses
that deal that says like a horrible deal
for me okay but hold on so that's the
most charitable possible interpretation
of why those arbitration things are good
if we step back from like that that
particular thing yeah in most cases
those types of barbra arbitration things
are significantly to the advantage of
the party that's most in place to impose
it so if you look at like in the
workplace if you look at when it comes
to environmental stuff whoever wants
that system is going to be
disproportionately benefiting from it at
the expense of the other party so I
don't know that yes panels let both
people nominate a judge and then they
both have to agree on a third panel
person it's not like it's not like the
person bringing suit picks three friends
to come over and evaluate whether or not
they win or lose no it's not but you I
mean I'm sure that you would grant that
these systems are subject to the same
type of regulatory capture that like
basically every you know it's the
regulator it's industry regulating the
regulators and that's the same problem
we have in the United States where you
know it's it's a capitalism for the gain
for the profits and social is
socializing the the costs and it's just
hard for me to say that I have no good
reason to think that they're proposing
that in good faith I mean I I just I
mean I can see where it might not be
perfect but I just can't think of like
if I let's say that I have a firm and
another country passes a law but I think
is hurting my firm yeah who should
arbitrate this if not like a third party
panel like who else should that want
that you would only ask the question
that way if you were already completely
bought into the status quo of the
multinational corporation there's
another way that this stuff can work
which is the same stuff that makes it so
that you have to figure that at that
situation out is the one that allows a
company that basically is an American
company to on paper be Irish and then
pay any taxes in the United States and
the answer is you you stop that
infrastructure a company has to be for
use you don't have multinational
companies and when you have
multinational companies but you regulate
their activity their behavior within
countries based on the laws of those
countries I'm not saying that it would
be an easy thing to do but it's just
like you have to that's a paradigm
Schieffelin though what do you do when a
country passes a law just to make your
firm non-competitive a country okay so
like what would be an example of that um
sure so we can use like a real-life
example in Canada there was a foreign
company that had a guess like that that
sold gas they're called ethyl Corp in
Canada passed a law that banned a
certain additive to fuel and only
impacted this company didn't impact any
of the other companies in Canada well I
think if I think this is [ __ ] and
they're only passing it to make me
non-competitive if not third-party
arbitration who should I appeal to their
I mean okay so this I'm that gets us to
like a much broader argument of like
what are the rights that a company
should have like isn't that something
there would be people who would say
that's the prerogative of Canada you you
have no right to sell your gas in Canada
and if that's what Canada decides then
what why I mean that that's totally
their right like that's not necessarily
my position but that is a position
that's that's not a trade position and
then you're saying like don't have trade
deals because like the natural extension
of where that gets us then is okay well
if your country I assume as a bad legal
system I'm never investing in your
country ever I'm never gonna start a
business there and screw you guys or if
you want to open up trade to another
country well why would I open up trade
with your country if any time a firm
from my country tries to sell in your
country you make them non-competitive
with your local legislation well you're
sort of moving the goalposts though
because you first started with like the
specific arbitration multi you know a
superseding
arbitration infrastructure for TPP but
now you're just saying like what if any
country does something that's bad for my
business so it's like that that is a
moving the goalposts of sorts wait but
that's the that's the fundamental
question I don't think it's moving the
goalposts the fundamental question is if
I have a firm and I wanted to be
competitive with firms in another
country that we're supposed to have open
trade with what do I do if that country
is engaging in discriminatory business
practices that favor their local
companies over a foreign one so this is
I think the strongest thing which is
if you have specific if you have a
particular agreement and expectations
that are part of a trade deal then the
question is how do you enforce that and
I completely agree that you need to have
some mechanism for that my skepticism of
the overarching way that TPP had it and
again I feel like it's just semi moot
because it's dead but part of the
problem with it was that it didn't seem
like it was the narrowest way to address
that particular issue okay I would be
super curious and hearing alternatives
this seemed like a pretty good standard
for resolving these disputes that
essentially like I'm gonna sue you
so what we're both gonna do is we're
both gonna find our expert who's gonna
rule on this and then both of us are
going to agree on a third person or if
we can't then our two people are going
to agree on a third person yeah and then
we're gonna and then they're going to
evaluate who's in the right here and you
need two votes to win your case
so not only get it I mean that seems
like a good way to resolve disputes
using third-party arbitration between a
firm in another country
I get it I think the issue I'm having is
that TPP in total was such a hand out to
multinational corporations which already
control like all aspects of everyone's
lives period and are raping and
pillaging the resources of the planet
that it feels to me like wait it wait a
second are we gonna just default to
giving these corporations everything
they want I think that well I mean like
of course if we're in a capitalist
framework and we were doing anything to
improve the status of an economy which
is what multilateral trade agreements
are for these are by definition going to
benefit the largest players in your
country that's just a that's just a
reality right now if you want to say
something like corporations have too
much power or inequality is too high I
can I agree with both of those
statements obviously but you don't
address this with trade policy you
address this with with a domestic policy
right hold on a second I don't know that
that's so hot let's back up for a second
though because if you when I step back
it's like okay TPP was going to
significantly strengthen patent and
copyright law to the benefit of huge
corporations at the expense of the
average person it was going to create
again this like extrajudicial
infrastructure for corporations that
even if you're
making some reasonable points about the
need for a system like it it's yet
another letting the companies figure out
how they're going to be regulated like
when you step back it's just letting big
corporations tell us how it is that they
want to be regulated and what it is that
they want to do and that I think is like
the fundamental problem I mean like I
can understand but like you're
presenting this with only one side like
the other side of this is that copyright
protections as much as we hate them on
the Internet are actually pretty
important to doing business if you're
going to invest a great deal of a
research and development into some
product you want to be able to
exclusively capture revenue through
selling that for some period of time one
of the huge problems that we talk about
right now but I think people I hope on
the left and right agree is that if you
set up a firm in some countries those
countries will make your firm transfer
intellectual property to other people
either to the state itself like in China
or to other competing firms and it's
like well [ __ ] well why would I ever
invest why I'm never going to set up a
company there if any software I transfer
or any proprietary knowledge is going to
be literally expropriated by the state
and then distributed to other companies
like I'm never gonna do that it's just
horrible so like I mean like this is one
of our huge critiques that we have with
China and it's arguably something that
the TPP would have given us a little bit
of leverage on that that another company
like a Chinese company couldn't do this
in another country that they're
operating in with an American firm
because now we can use the TPP to bring
suit against them or something
yeah I mean like the the copyright stuff
maybe goes too far but this is more of a
broader critique on copyright law not on
the TPP because well let me let me quote
an expert on trade named Donald Trump
okay once said we don't want to take a
hammer when a velvet glove would work or
something like that and and I'm sort of
joking because Trump's not an expert on
trade but what I mean is I think that
all of the issues that you're bringing
up could be dealt with in far more
narrow ways than the way that the TPP
was doing it and I am NOT grieving the
death of TPP okay I I mean I'd be
interested in hearing those it's usually
I just hear usually all of the
accusations just sounds to me like
somebody's my corporation bad and then
like that's like the default like no no
no do with it
I am i I am I am NOT an
capitalist I am a social democrat and I
am completely clear on there are certain
types of advancements that you need the
infrastructure of a corporation to most
effectively kind of like carry the risk
and bear the research and development
costs in connection with obviously the
Commons and the fact that a lot of the
people making those advancements have
public school education 'he's like okay
i'm tempering it with social democracy
so I'm not like an anti corporate guy it
I just think that again there are far
more even with like copyright you can't
even say here's the way to deal with
copyright and patents dealing with it in
entertainment media versus
pharmaceutical patents like they need to
be dealt with differently in their
different solutions in each yeah I don't
necessarily disagree I just I mean it's
just it's crazy to me that if you have
like a massive agreement that we all
agree provide some benefits that like a
few critiques of different things within
this agreement let you scrap the whole
thing like that's just like like it
would be like car shopping and you go
through and you find a perfect car good
gas mileage a lot of power a lot of
space yeah I don't really like the seats
and I think we could just do way better
on that so screw this whole vehicle and
it's like that's how I shop for cars as
soon as the seats aren't comfortable I'm
looking at a different dealership I mean
that makes it gay but like if at the end
of the day if you're walking to work
every day it seems like you kind of shot
yourself in the foot by being too
extremely i don't maybe I'm too
incrementalist on my approach to a lot
of these deals but I don't know I mean I
I mean I understand that there are
narrower ways to deal with each of the
things that you like about TPP
individually that would not create I
mean the other thing is once you get
into something like TPP it's sort of
like the tariffs that Trump has put in
place the off-ramp is extraordinarily
long and difficult so for me wrapping so
much stuff into one deal in this way
especially when so much of it is
questionable when we could deal with all
of these things individually doesn't
seem like the wisest path forward well
but I mean these trade agreements are
usually huge the European Union is huge
NAFTA is huge like these these trade
agreements are always going to be
massive because there's so much there's
so many side agreements that you have to
make but have to address the specific
policies in every country and it just
seems like by walking away from it
America basically just said screw it
we're
seeing all of that influence in the in
the southeast Pacific region like we
just we don't have it anymore and now
China does because we walked away from
it the cut the ten remaining countries
signed on to it yeah with Japan leading
them and now China is moving through
with their initiatives to build out all
of their infrastructure across all of
Asia and Africa and we're just like
sitting here like twiddling our thumbs
getting into trade Wars and and yeah
locking ourselves in a box I completely
agree with you Russia now I mean Russia
the the Russia China us sort of like
super power dynamics have gone
dramatically out of the USS favor yeah
now you've got Russia making deals with
China for energy harvesting you've got
China going to India for I don't
remember if it's like aluminum or steel
because of the tariffs I mean it's like
everybody's basically fine other than us
as a result of this yeah because those
countries are not ignoring like the
globalist reality that we're facing and
a faster you globalized and the bigger
foothold you get in a global market like
the stronger your countries gonna be
China absolutely understands that but
then it seems like we're scared in the
West because of dumb [ __ ] going on
you've got like the United Kingdom
leaving the largest unified market in
the world
you've got the United States on
ironically engaging in trade wars the
largest trading partner that is actually
damaging not only our markets but our
job markets as well in the United States
like it's insane to me that people are
like all of a sudden we became
isolationist in like ten years I have no
idea what happened it's crazy hey is
this like what twitch is all about where
we just randomly argue about stuff oh
yeah sure yeah I scream for ten hours I
talk about a lot of random [ __ ] but I'm
sorry wow this is crazy well listen I
I'm slowly learning what I'm doing on
Twitch and one of the things I saw is
that your channel is like at the top
refer to mine so like that's good right
I'm a big twitch streamer okay I might
be a little boy on YouTube but I'm a big
guy here on Twitch right you're you're
doing well on YouTube as well I'm doing
okay yeah yeah alright I got a like take
phone calls from my audience and stuff
yeah all right well hey have fun thanks
for the conversation all right yep
sounds good I'll talk to you soon yeah
see ya okay destiny all right well
whoever suggested that that was a good
idea I like that that that should be
clipped and put on youtube right I mean
that was like a good I think that was a
good conversation I don't know it's
funny I'm reading that people are saying
that that was intense and destiny was
triggered but that seemed pretty normal
to me I don't know
okay stream for ten hours a day what the
hell yeah when I went to dinner with
destiny and Hassan in LA a couple months
ago they both were telling me they
stream like eight to ten hours a day and
that they aspire to more it's like well
I aspire to do last not more I don't
know what that's about
okay I've got like a ton of people to
thank here so let me let me see here
my thing here only goes back a certain
way so chazzy hat thanks for the twitch
prime sub chain chomsky one with 400
bits which I appreciate
pork pork 84 thanks for the twitch prime
sub loora loora master echo Master Choa
thanks for the twitch prime sub week up
huh gunner week a pal gunner twitch
prime sub Thank You Jen with no plane
gave it to your one sub to Adele's green
man 137 gave it to your one sub - classy
Andy nineteen which I appreciate
transcend subscribe to twitch prime
thank you [ __ ] seven four eight six
subscribed at Pier one
thanks for the bits crab Abbie crab a be
itchy dingleberry oh okay that might be
my cousin it she dingleberry that's his
handle subscribe to its prime who dat
fam subscribe a Touch prime origins and
tall tales thanks for the bits Davy so
subscribed with prime and Captain
snuggles subscribed with prime if you
are coming over from like my main pre
twitch audience if you have Amazon Prime
you can support me it won't cost you
anything but it counts as a paid
subscription for me you subscribe to my
channel with twitch prime if you don't
know how to do that you can easily
google it you've got to connect your
Amazon account to twitch Prime please do
that please do that because it costs you
nothing and a huge announcement we have
our first tier 2 subscriber ever -
vitamin has subscribed at tier 2 which I
really appreciate
we have not had any tier 2 subscribers
so far but now we do okay there are a
couple new website members
so Thomas Johnston was already number
four of the
evening Yvonne let's Koh is number five
Kyle wolf schlager is number six
Rio Diaz is number seven and Ann ruddy
is number eight
thanks guys really appreciate that let
me update the on-screen graphic we are
at 8 of 15 members and if we get to 15
website members infos over there number
is up there I'll open up the phone lines
and I would love to hear from some of
you folks oh and Cesar and Jay has
subscribed at tier 2 that's our second
tier 2 subscriber I also want to thank
El coops and homestar for their tier 1
subscriptions and flibberty flab who
cheered a hundred and seventy-seven bits
and Schneids ease with the twitch Prime
subscription which I very much
appreciate ok yeah find out more at
David 303 303 300 channels oppai de que
fred thanks for the tier 2 subscription
and stop the presses meow the great has
subscribed with tier 3 tier 3 comes with
something amazing with a tier 3
subscription once our emotes get
approved you will have a producer Lewis
e mode producer Lewis is a former david
pakman show producer who actually
streams on Twitch and coined a lot of
urban dictionary phrases and that's a
really a really special thing to have
speaking of which let me pull that up
let me pull up urban dictionary here
because this is actually something
people might be interested in okay so
there's a few urban dictionary terms
that are from the David Pakman show
one is hatred from hatred mail and the
top definition as you can see please up
vote the top definition a caller to the
David Pakman show who records hatred
mail comments expressing his or her
ultra conservative views in a derogatory
manner
Uncle Sam hates minorities he's a true
hatred okay
and then the second definition has my
name misspelled so that's why it
actually has more upvotes
disturbingly enough and then the third
definition also mentions the david
pakman show which is great actually
okay so hate reott is one of our urban
dictionary terms fever --nt is another
one this one is for from former producer
lewis fever an adjective wildly zealous
it's a portmanteau of feverish and
fervent unintentionally coined by Louis
Motamedi of the David Pakman show this
is a direct quote from 2014 when Louis
said it it seems like the only people
who are going to vote for Rand Paul are
that small libertarian section of the
Republican Party and they're very
passionate and favorite and they support
him with every fiber of their being so
there's that now there's another one
from today's show which is feed a pile
feed a pile couldn't okay so it's not
there yet
it's a hay tree otic misspelling of
pedophile and I've asked for people to
add feed a pile to urban dictionary with
a reference to the David Pakman show so
maybe people will do that soon and I
think there are more is the Sam cedar in
my chat actually Sam account created
January 25th following since August 6th
which is yesterday I wonder if that's oh
it's not okay it's not Sam cedar got it
that makes sense yeah it doesn't seem
like something Sam would do okay so
that's that
let me see before I move on oh no I
don't have any more website members to
thank seven more website Oh a night
people said I should update this to say
of 15 website members just to make that
clear okay
good alright so tomorrow on the show I'm
going to be doing a story the working
title is something like what happened to
the good guys with guns and we're going
to talk about just like the the obvious
ridiculousness of the idea that more
people with guns at chaotic mass
shootings that often last 30 to 60
seconds are realistically going to stop
a mask
in their tracks my argument for a very
long time has been that you've got a
mass shooting going on and there's a
so-called good guy with a gun who shows
up and starts shooting and then police
show up a minute later police are just
going to see two people with guns and
are likely going to engage both of them
so we're gonna deal with that tomorrow
and I'm looking forward to talking about
that there's this good piece in time by
mijita Gajanan and Sonia Mansoor about
the particulars of why good guys with
guns didn't do anything in Texas and
Ohio and I know that the NRA has their
talking points they'll say well when you
have a gun-free zone you the people that
abide by the law don't have guns but the
people that ignore the law have them and
that's the problem and of course that
makes no sense so we're going to talk
about that on the show tomorrow people
asking if I'm Pro Second Amendment
that's a sort of a silly question
the Second Amendment exists we need gun
safety regulations they don't violate
the Second Amendment I will also talk
tomorrow about Elizabeth Warren's
proposal for a public option for the
Internet I've already done a bunch of
research on this story I really like
this idea I mean listen number one I
love that Elizabeth Warren has been
slowly gaining traction in this campaign
with proposals that are detailed and
this is healthcare this is her wealth
tax whatever doesn't matter if you agree
with them or not she's talking about
policy which I love this is a great
O'Daniel meirin's wrote this I know
Daniel actually this is a great policy
that she has put out which would
basically create a grant program as this
Huff Post article says which would cover
90 percent of the costs for building
public internet for nonprofits or coops
or cities if you are a for-profit
utility you would be ineligible for this
and I think that this is great and I'm
gonna be talking about this tomorrow I
will also be talking tomorrow about this
tweet now there's some background here
this tweet is one in which Donald Trump
is promoting oann called the
one American news network it is a toxic
and disgusting network that is even
crazier than Fox News I predicted months
ago that Donald Trump if he gets
displeased with Fox News will start
promoting Oh a n he did it today and I'm
going to talk about that and I'll talk a
little bit about Oh a n and those are
just a few of the stories I'll be
talking about tomorrow
one other thing well I'll show you my
multi Reddit in a second there's a few
questions here let me see here
do you agree with Ezra Klein that Warren
is the best policy communicator of all
the candidates she is a very good policy
communicator is she the best maybe so
maybe so
thoughts on Hasan [ __ ] Urban Dictionary
I'm scared to look it up with see the
Sun [ __ ] okay yeah I don't know I don't
know if they said this must be a
different Hasan [ __ ] than the one that
I know that's all I'll say their L coop
says hey you have a thousand viewers so
quickly will you do podcasts like Rajas
show I don't know what that is what's
Rajas show can anyone tell me Roz's show
whose ROG don't do it I don't know what
that is
don't tell me what it is it's a hot mess
ROG show is a variety show on twitch
don't do it
Raj Patel it's a dating show it's like a
political roundtable I have no plans I
have no preconceived notions about what
I am or or I'm not going to do epoch
spawner thanks for the twitch prime sub
news o wrath and bar to 123 Thank You D
P fan thanks for subscribing with prime
and Sid Harrell and Cable Guy 707 thank
you very much we are still looking for
seven more website members and I'll open
up the phone lines the phone number is
six one seven eight three zero 47 50
with the push of a button I can open the
phone line and then you can call in and
I'll talk to people if we get seven more
website members website memberships are
great because we get 98% of the money
almost any platform online where you're
contributing to people I won't name them
because they all seem to have rules
against talking about this but no matter
which one it is including the one we're
on they take a portion of what you
contribute and our website we just paid
2.9 percent payment processing and we
get the rest so that's why we promote
that aggressively and you know the
number up there and all of that stuff so
if people want the phone lines open
let's do it David your images on screen
are scuffed it's distracting alt f4
should fix it I don't even know what
that means my images are scuffed well
I'll put the number on screen maybe if
we actually open the phone lines will I
ever do a discord talk room instead of
instead of calls I don't know there's
only an unofficial discord and I'm
scared to link that with my official
streams so I'm not sure about that
you should watch Prager you on fox or
fox videos and comment on them people
love this stuff make sure to rate at the
end of your stream today I don't know
how to raid can someone explain to me
how I raid and what I would raid and how
I do it
slash rated channel name okay and what
does that do
does that basically just send everybody
over to some other channel oh go to
their Channel and click host or raid
click host raid Hasan hmm interesting
all right let's see what's up with
Prague are you I haven't seen what
they've been doing Prager you follows me
on Twitter interestingly Sam Harris
started following me on Twitter
politicians lie whoa see what's going on
here media lied about Trump's
charlottesville comments boring should
Americans pay slavery reparations just
like who cares what the what the people
they talk do you have to say about this
stuff eliminating the death penalty
cheapens murder
you can't fix other people but you can
fix yourself okay is that like Peterson
stuff
Candace Owens talk to Steve Bannon let's
take a look at that listen up the soap
you shower with you probably haven't
even questioned what bar soap quiet on
set Thanks
alright guys we are rolling into a
really special episode of the Candice
Owens show if you notice this is not my
normal cave what I have behind me is a
mile of the border wall being built I am
here and I'm with someone who I've been
dying to speak to really interested in a
lot of stuff that he's doing si Bannon
welcome to the kind of sewing shop well
Candace thank you and welcome here to
Sunland Park what is he doing that's so
interesting like what how could you what
that's that's already weird like what is
there that he does that would be
interesting New Mexico and we build the
walls first first three cores of a model
wall I have a question how did you get
mixed up into this what Brian Coal Fired
the leader in founder of this he's the
most wounded veteran in history the Air
Force has ever lived
he started this go fund me page during
the depths of my present Trump was
fighting the swamp and fighting a
burning fire fact this is the summers
thing right like isn't this the piece of
the wall that is like not even on the
border or something like that from the
guy that scammed people for like 20
million 19 Brian we don't go funny I
think he went on TV and said hey it's
that president ROM for building a wall
when we get private donations what
happened the donations came in but you
couldn't designate these to go fill the
wall the way the rules work is that it's
just gotta go to Treasury and so he was
kind of torn somebody put me in touch
with him he came up to the Breitbart
embassy in DC we sat down and I just
said I said look it's pretty simple
I want you to go build a wall so the
people did time to write a check to the
Treasury they build a wall I mean it's
yeah isn't this thing now under criminal
investigation like someone's pointing
out Boies is pointing that I thought
that this entire thing was was an actual
like legit scam oh I said there's enough
expertise out there we put together
board of advisers go find he said you
have to go back to all 20 million
dollars and you have to tell them
instead of the money just one who the
Treasury you're now gonna actually build
a wall and I think 16 million dollars
opted in so that's why we started oh I
didn't get that you actually I donated
so much in some because I was like this
is amazing I would gladly go towards
building it because she's donating money
I've said before you would have to be a
complete idiot to donate money to this
stupid project and she says I donated a
ton of money to the bigger teams this
entire presidency and what they sort of
conservative kickback if you want it all
about we don't need government right you
can do stuff on your own and people sort
of forget that like it's like we need
somebody bigger overreaching to organize
things and this is so grassroots right
really you don't need government to take
land from people that they may not want
a wall built on well okay I mean if
you're against that but you want to
build the wall the only alternative is
people start taking border border
property by force which also doesn't
make a lot of sense by the way the for
Maine does so you're one of one of the
16 million there's $14 gap 80% those
people we never could get there some
reason every
there's money at the end of the show I
get $20 in something I never got we
actually went backwards were trying to
go back to you email to say what we're
gonna build the wall and the amazing
thing is it's like 90% of the first 60
million hit right ways to take go do it
I think if you look at the southern
border crises look the board crisis you
certainly need in the principal
responsibility for the sovereignty of
the country the security country
obviously is the government we present
from suing they're building massive
amounts of wall I mean right here we're
right next to mile marker one way to say
she just said you don't need the
government to do stuff and then now
Bannon is saying you do and it's Trump
and the government that need to be
dealing with what are these people
talking about the Rio Grande River is
right next to us that is from the Gulf
of Mexico right up to here is the border
between Mexico and United States here it
pivots and that mile marker 1 is the
first mile marker and to go all the way
across all the San Diego so it's nothing
but high deserts here's we got a big
building big swaths of wall what we do
we're like the Special Forces
it's those areas like here the Cristo
Rey mountain that's Army Corps of
Engineers it either Dean is too hard to
build or don't need to be built in
private land and we go to private
landowners and work with them so what
you're sitting here today is a wall that
was built really you're asking for dark
mode I don't even know how to switch to
on its own for days all the way up that
mountain and you had the pleasure of
taking that Jeep it is doctrine I don't
think people realize I certainly didn't
when you talk about it you think it just
like there's just this flat space and
why can't we build a wall but this is
really tough terrain and you can see why
this advantageous are people that are
legal just come right over and get in
here and this is a particularly tough
area come so he could I talk about what
goes on here in terms of drug
trafficking and sex traffic well here's
how we even got the idea this is one of
the dumbest interviews I've seen I mean
let me just skip to the middle just to
see something else well the entire time
on one paycheck you can't do that in
America today and until we bring these
jobs back until we bring these
manufacturing jobs back before we show
opportunities to people african-american
Hispanic and the working class in this
country and showing opportunities of
high value-added manufacturing jobs I
don't I don't sit there go oh I can't
believe they're socialists they're
socialists because of all you haven't
given an alternative and until we get in
the way we're not even alternative you
have to break the cartel on Wall Street
grip on Washington DC you have to break
these global corporations country to
companies that don't think that there's
no right way they do not put American
workers first what they do is they put
their own profits for us and if they
have to chase slave labor in China
they're a che slave labor in China
financed by the pension funds of
working-class people here and I
understand this is where Dennis Prager
and a lot of my comrades on the right
say pan your this is where you know we
leave your populism because we believe
in the auction school economics whoa hey
the author school economics doesn't work
in here
doesn't work we're a perfect example of
why it doesn't work we've allowed he
concentration of power a concentration
of wealth that is now over long before
local system the reason Donald Trump is
president stationary entities but the
working class people in this country
understood that the elites had did not
believe in American greatness it hit
sold out American greatness to Asia to
the party of Davos and they were
comforted because they were making more
money and had more concentrated wealth
labor overhead but working-class people
in Michigan in Wisconsin in Pennsylvania
Iowa Ohio they understood that America
could be returned to her greatness with
a leader like down from that focus on
you know so he's right about identifying
a problem but he's wrong that Trump is
the solution obviously that's a complete
and total joke
okay let me I don't know how much of
this I can tolerate but let me thank a
couple of other people Selah underscore
subscribed with prime Montes OMA
subscribed with prime hockey for life
seventy-four gave out a Tier one
community sub gift I've never seen that
before I don't know how that works but
that is interesting okay let me look at
an updated number of new members oh
there's nobody new maybe people don't
want the phone lines opened up we've got
seven more website members this is real
fast okay
you go to join pakman.com it's dirt
cheap the $6 a month membership with
that code saves you 40 percent three
dollars and sixty cents a month then the
number up there goes up over there up
there and then I'll open up the phone
lines and oh we got somebody Paul Roy or
Paul Roy has signed up so that gets us
to nine
we're only six away from opening up the
phone lines which I would love to do
okay let me show you something else that
I wanted to talk about so I have like
ass up I have an internal subreddit
where I have all of these different news
reddit's that I use to keep an eye on
just what's happening in the news and
look for stories and there's a lot of
good stuff and a lot of crazy stuff so
like for example federal judge orders
release of Khashoggi records by US
government okay I probably wouldn't
cover that worin pledges to restore net
neutrality if elected I already told you
I'm covering that st. Louis Sargent
there are white supremacists on the
police force that's interesting
asked reddit yeah if you're Satan's
half-wit brother I don't know anything
about that
lawyers protesting events in Hong Kong
probably not the right story for me up
thing news sometimes gives me it gives
me interesting stuff I don't know if
this is the right place to post this
huge smile on my face
overweight dog was about to be
euthanized shed more than a hundred
pounds that's interesting
oh I mentioned this before how is it
possible corporations pay zero tax many
corporations pay zero tax plus the
billions more hidden in tax havens how
is that legal it's legal because they
make the laws that's literally what I
said to destiny when we were just
talking a little while ago a cover the
overweight up yeah that's a good story
Tucker calling white supremacy a hoax
i I'm a cover tomorrow what else here
I'm not seeing anything obvious for my
show mmm yeah in any case this is a tool
that I use in order to in order to find
stories for the show and sometimes I'll
look at Google News let's see what's on
there Trump visits the grieving and
Stokes divisions yeah I mean that
doesn't take a genius to per have
predicted Dayton Mayor confused by
Trump's criticism of how she described
his visit Canada authorities believe
they found the bodies of suspects and
killings Schumer blasts red flag yeah
I'm not seeing any obvious stuff here
here's who won the second democratic
debate I talked about that ice raids on
Mississippi food processing plants yeah
anyway I'm not seeing completely obvious
stuff millionaire fugitive denied why
does he have no shirt millionaire
fugitive denied bail in US Court after
being on the run for four years see what
that's about man it's just ads
everywhere
I wanted to see this guys figure out why
he was not wearing a shirt use adblock
people are saying would adblock listen
here's what let me let me talk about
adblock for a second the reason I don't
use adblock is because I also depend on
people watching ads on my stuff I get it
on stream I just shouldn't do it but you
block okay let's see what's up here
back in custody after four years on the
run Southern California real estate
investor Peter chat wick as the called
Mexico he's accused of killing his wife
in 2012 police say he fled in 2015 after
emptying his bank accounts investigators
say he read books about how to live off
the grid Siegfried and Roy are speaking
out about that and now I'm actually what
are zigfried and Roy's speaking out
attack that ended their Las Vegas show a
tiger named Manticore dragged Roy by the
neck in 2003 nearly killing him
the duo have always insisted it was a
tragic mistake saying that Roy had a
stroke
prompting the 700-pound tiger to lunge
while trying to help Roy
during an exclusive interview with ABC's
Debra Robert Siegfried disputes Montek
horse trainer who recently claimed that
Roy was to blame for the attack Chris
Lawrence has come forward and saying I
know that Roy had not been paying as
much attention to the tiger that he
changed the routine that night that it
threw him off and that Roy essentially
was to blame was he I told you
Roy we're jump cut they're fast out he
had a stroke in reality how we can
change the routine he book he noticed
heben was not on stage he was backstage
who even finds this Tiger stuff
interesting like I genuinely just find
nothing even remotely interesting about
it it's weird okay a robo dope has
subscribed with prime and Sam Dean has
subscribed with prime and we have some
new website subscribers let's see who
we've got
your crow Z or your crow it's I'm not
sure how to pronounce it is a new member
Fredrick Iverson or even is a new member
Sherman Bell is a new member and
Christopher Knight has signed up on my
website so that gets us to 13 of 15
we're opening up the phone lines right
like we're not gonna we're not gonna
miss out on this opportunity given that
we're so close I assume that we're going
to get there with just two more website
members would I consider putting that
multi reddit as public oh that's that's
in maybe I'll think about that David
talked to his son he just went live are
we really doing this if I if I go and
try to talk to her son I think that will
I do a drum livestream I think that
it'll just derail maybe I can just very
briefly ask him about the debate with
genk let me see let me find his thing
here a son hey do you want to talk five
minutes on stream about how the debate
went let's see what he says
he may not even be paying attention to
like dis court private messages I don't
know there was a disagreement well he
debated Genk yeah I know he's not even
is he even online I don't even know
what's going on here streaming it shows
that he's streaming Oh with me and jank
oh yes see what he has to say
people saying his son did okay he says
hold on just went live oh my bad
he's prepping food how long are you
streaming I actually don't know the
answer to that he has a five minute in
Truckee
okay I guess he does want to talk about
it briefly I followed destiny for people
who are talking telling me to follow
destiny okay James Stephens has signed
up on my website that's a nice
development let me get back here let me
get back here to putting the graphics up
on screen so that gets us to fourteen
one more and we will open the phone
lines this is exciting we open the phone
lines when we add like 6,500 people on
the stream during the debates but this
is just like a normal stream is there a
queue to be destroyed with facts or
logic right now there is a queue yeah
and I should get a streamer to help me
with bttv and ffz emotes
yeah that's an idea I don't know what
any of those things are but someone
mentioned the other one the other day a
happy dog all has cheered to bits
origins and tall tales has cheered
another hundred bits which I appreciate
go on the scuf podcast yeah I think I
actually I think I know who that is no
now I know who hutch is I don't know
what scuf is will I be streaming
regularly yeah I mean to some degree I
will don't go on scuffed people are
saying it's scuffed bad I don't know
okay so if people want the phone lines
opened we're very very close it would
just be one more subscriber and I've got
to hold true to it because if I say that
we need like a certain number of people
and then we don't get it and then I open
the phone lines anyway it's uh it's it's
just like what what kind of a message am
i sending if I do that I just really
can't do that it's a scuffed is lowbrow
it's at which reality show I'd be the
most educated person on there or other
people saying it's good all right or
it's bad wait is scuffed the same thing
as train wreck I have no idea what these
people are talking about
it is Oh scuffed and trainwreck is the
same thing interesting okay all right
Peter her clots has signed up for a
membership that gets us to 15 and I will
open the phone lines at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47
50 let me update that on the stream
where can I do that oh I see where it is
ok
call 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 all right let me
unblock the phone lines voicemail is off
oh and I've got it actually how I got to
get myself connected to the phone system
so let me get that going because that
takes a second if you call in now it
will put you in the queue all right I'm
just getting myself connected here thank
you for calling in to the David Pakman
show
please do not use speakerphone have your
question ready and listen for David to
call out your area code right
whoa okay there are a lot of people who
are already holding okay well we I guess
while we wait for her son let's what do
we want to do first here hold on a
second
my son is over there okay so let me I
just don't want to miss when he's ready
oh is this even gonna work actually I've
never done this on this computer before
so we need to see if this stuff is even
gonna work let's see let's try to go to
Sabrina Zafar Sabrina we haven't talked
to her for a little bit what's going on
Sabrina Sabrina oh hey there you are oh
yeah hi how are you good what's going on
good so I'm just wondering I have a
couple of co-workers who are pretty
conservative and every time the gun
rights issue comes up they always
mention like oh the government could
overthrow us that I in common you know
Trump is a fascist and their argument is
just we fundamentally fundamentally have
the right to have guns just in case the
government overthrows you and I always
kind of don't know how to respond to
that because they always say oh well
that's what happens in the American
Revolution and like how would you
respond to something like that well okay
so how have you responded so far well I
tell them that but back in the
Revolutionary that sort of handled the
guns and I guess there's disagreement as
to how formal the militias were if they
were just ordinary people being called
to arms in a way if they're actually
like police forces back then I mean and
yeah I'd have to think about that a
little bit to be honest Oh son yes
what's going on dude
Sabrina can you hear her son no oh
that's the weirdest thing let me think
about that Sabrina and let me let me
just check in with Hasan about what's
going on I'm not exactly sure how I
would answer it's not it's a
conversation I would probably try to
avoid altogether to be honest but yeah
okay oh all right Nix appreciate it
thank you I'm taking calls over here
Hasan but I am okay yeah yeah I'm dude
you got a you got an operation going on
there you got your calling help you
better watch out no terms of service
violations all right
yes someone said if anyone says the
n-word I should like mute it or
something like that yeah if I'm doing to
be honestly if I'm doing a viewer
Collins you gotta have like moderators
to screen them ahead of time probably
are you second if if I just randomly if
someone just randomly uses the n-word
once then like that's a problem
yes oh man yeah yet witch's term
services quite rigorous but and and
their application is heavily contested
however at least they have a Terms of
Service and that kind of that kind of
changes the dynamic of the platform and
the in the political commentary that
people can engage with on the platform
it's it's it's like a bit it's kind of
bad but also pretty good too does that
make sense it does yeah but it's just
like you know that that's I don't know
how I can totally police that you know
oh yeah I know yeah um I don't know if
you know this but I got banned well this
is I've gotten been three times now are
you serious yeah I've owned I've only
been on the platform for so long but
I've gotten ban three times and like
some people literally get banned for
like saying the n-word or saying the
f-word or something like that yeah I got
banned for watching a piece of a Michael
Moore documentary
it wasn't like DMCA or anything it was
just like I was watching a Michael Moore
documentary and apparently there was
like a flash like a quick flash on the
screen of like a real dead body from
yeah we were talking about like Latin
American atrocities that the United
States is committed or participated in
and you know they're so bad that it's a
violation of the Terms of Service on on
Twitter they say real gore like you
can't show real gore they're very you
know they're very strict on that stuff
just so you know that's good to know I
appreciate that so how did the whole
thing with Jenko um the thing with jag
went really well I think a lot of people
are very excited kind of like you
obviously like I agree with most of
Jenks positions except for like some
some disagreements that I would consider
quite significant but he framed it like
he framed it really effectively he
framed it as like a capitalism he framed
capitalism is a good thing by saying
like oh well the only time we ever been
close to true capitalism is in the in
the era between like in the FDR New Deal
era all the way to like 1978 yep and I
thought he that was like pretty
effective framing he refused to engage
with like any sort of Marxist
fundamentals like if I tried to talk
about like a you know exploitation or
anything like that he was just he would
flip it over back to like the colloquial
understanding of exploitation right and
the last thing that he said which I
think you might agree with as well is
that the exploitation of the third world
is acceptable considering the marginal
improvements or in his words were
drastic improvements that the third
world has seen under under capitalism
yeah I mean I don't totally disagree
it's just like you know the hard thing
about it is as soon as you say that then
people are like what are you some kind
of like capitalist chill or something
like that so it's just hard to really
like have a non-ideological conversation
but I'm gonna try to watch it is is that
show is it is that a paywall show and is
it a permanent show or is it a summer
show so we're doing a test run at the
moment to see how it is it's it's kind
of like a spiritual successor to
aggressive progressive kind of oh I
didn't realize that was half of it is
behind a paywall so the way we're doing
it is like Tuesday shows I mean you can
just I don't know just freaking pirate
it like it's not that hard you know
natural yeah obviously but which is
funny cause like now
a particular streamers audience is
started calling me paywall pygar look as
though I have any say on this but yeah
so half of its gonna be half of that
debate is actually behind a paywall but
normally the way we're doing the doing
the show is the first show is 12:00 to
1:00 p.m. live streamed and then also
everyone can access it and then my
second show every week is gonna be on
Friday again 12:00 to 1:00 p.m. and that
show will be behind a paywall for a
members-only got it got it got it pretty
basic like model that other podcasts and
and and most of the content creators use
to drive membership so that's what we're
trying to do but it could change down
the line
who's the next person you'll debate on
there um the net so it's not actually a
debate stream probably it's actually
going to be I will be having a lot of
guests I'm some of the guests are going
to be Michael Brooks coming up next
Tuesday we're not going to be debating
though we're actually going to talk
about like the history of agitated
propaganda and my point is I want to
talk about the news like talk about
what's happening in the world but from a
leftist perspective while also tying it
back to historical context so like what
I'm going to be doing with agitprop the
episode on agitated propaganda is like
talk about the anti-racist agitated
propaganda like the history of communist
agitprop and how agitated propaganda was
used to to radicalize like black workers
in America and and things like that and
how there are some resemblances to the
way that people are talking about like
Russia Gate I don't know if you remember
like New York Times wrote an article and
a couple other mainstream media outlets
actually wrote an article about how like
black lives matter was targeted by
Russian ibattz or whatever and and it's
it's obviously not like a direct
comparison because they're they also
educated like Russia now is also
agitating folks like white supremacist
rhetoric too
sure um but I'm just using that like
talk about Russia talk about Russia gate
and then also talk about
what we should be doing like what the
next steps are I am a pro starting the
impeachment proceedings I don't know if
you have a different opinion I'm in
favor of an inquiry right away yeah
first yeah oh yeah and are your guests
all gonna be in studio or some will be
like remote via Skype or whatever no
remote via Skype if you want to come on
that'd be awesome actually I'd love to
have you on oh sure I would love to yeah
hell yeah but no only Jake was in studio
we're seeing like what who the guests
are going to be in what availabilities
there are right and depending on that
the issue of course is that I'm on the
west coast so no one is out here
unfortunately
right right right all right well good
I'm gonna try to check out that debate
and awesome I'm gonna get back to taking
some phone calls all right by the way
David if you have any questions like
don't hesitate to ask like there's
emails and stuff like this is a really
complicated like completely new dynamic
to get into oh yeah I've got us all I've
got seven emotes pending okay yeah yeah
all right good good good start there's
like bttv and stuff like I do you have
moderators already I've got a five of
them I don't know how many are in the
chat right now okay you're gonna
definitely need a lot of moderators for
sure and you're gonna you're gonna need
like and if anyone from my audience like
if you if you guys are watching like
David's content and whatever and you
should definitely go and offer to help
him out because that's how I started off
as well it's like very communal here
yeah like my moderators have helped me
throughout the entire process like
helped me set up the discord helped me
set up the set of the page like I almost
everything that you see on my twitch
page is like fan-made also yeah so all
right sounds good I'll talk to you soon
all right peace dude later it seems like
I was on you could hear like my audio in
the background there that was that was
interesting alright let's take a few
more calls at 6 1 7 8 3-0 47 50 going to
our caller from the 508 area code
possible local caller here yeah you're
correct I'm from Worcester Massachusetts
how are you hey Jess I'm good today
hoping I could talk to you thank you so
much appreciate
my brain and recovery mode from so many
high-level important is very very good I
like that alright so um my question I
guess as a northeastern ER so I'm the
big fan of you as well as Conklin skin
since theater okay you know you're the
other one for Massachusetts extra props
for that no Sam cedar is from Worcester
yeah yeah you live in New York now
though current right yes yes yes
yeah yeah I actually didn't know that oh
that's cool yeah there you go yeah so
but I've noticed despite being pretty
close proximity or at least by internet
standard right um the three of you
haven't really done that much together
early they're certainly not like as a
trio as a trio we were on a panel at
politican yeah I mean it's like so for
from my thing I try to not have people
on that do the same thing I do so that's
why I just don't tend to have too many
other political commentators on because
it's like it's the same thing that I'm
doing so I try to have on like academic
scientists politicians people who do
other stuff former extremists or
whatever but we've done stuff together
like in person I think oh yeah and yeah
I actually wasn't aware of Politico and
unfortunately actually had a lot of
things going on my personally so I kind
of missed last year's whole poetic on
thing I kind of want to pay attention to
the bread tomb scene during that time to
look to the what were you paying
attention
tombstone no calculon you refer to you
guys bread - granite Oh Oh bread - bread
xub yeah I don't really know what that
is yeah yeah I'm not super like it's a
term I've heard Kyle you got it maybe
you could look into that yeah it's
something you'd want to a debt or not
yes I will I will research and decide
for sure yeah let me get to some other
callers I appreciate the call always
good to hear from a local and please
please call in again let's try the 863
area code who's calling today from
6:3 this is the action florida alright
very good
hi you said before that oh one no no go
ahead go ahead
ok you said before that door tearing
right I I've not said that socialism per
se is authoritarian but that I've not
heard too many good takes as to how you
mandate socialism without some degree of
authoritarianism okay my question was
does that include libertarian socialism
such as an Urkel communism or
anarcho-syndicalism well typically with
some of those modalities you you you
still end up with so-called strongmen
enforcing what they want with guns it's
just someone other than the government
doing it oh you mean like during the
revolution suppose revolution or even
after I mean if it eventually unless
you're you're going to really have true
Anarchy where part of the anarchic
status quo would probably involve people
with guns as well I mean you know as
people in my chat are saying it's it's a
spectrum and there are up there
significant degrees of authoritarianism
in the implementation and maintenance of
a lot of those systems that a lot of
people just don't talk about okay thanks
go all right okay thank you very good
appreciate the phone call let's try our
caller from the nine-oh-nine area code
whose caller from 909 909 do you have us
muted because I can't hear you
No all right 909 I guess I will let you
go let's go to our caller from the four
one seven area code who's calling today
from four one seven
hey David thank you for having me on
um I actually wanted to tell us to worry
but also a couple of questions because
it kind of ties into that but if you
don't mind anyways well that's a lot of
stuff and I don't want to be rude to
other people who are holding so maybe
maybe just pick one of your questions
might be a good way to go okay
it basically has something to do with
mine um lungs I guess my question is
yeah sorry um do you think that a
student should be punished more if they
protest should students be punished more
if they protest what if they are
protesting things like the abortion bans
that happened in May because that's the
kind of story that but kind of don't
want in that because the students where
and punished by who let me I'm not sure
I really understand what you're talking
the basically if they're being punished
partially due to something that wasn't
necessarily their fault okay so which
school did this happen it this happened
in high school I don't know a thing
about it to be perfectly honest but my
general view is anybody who is just
expressing their speech in a way that is
constitutionally protected if no laws
are being broken if they're not you know
targeting groups on the basis of
identity and protected classes I mean I
just don't know what how you justify
punishment for that alright I get that I
knew you didn't know for now alright
very good well what callback and we can
deal with the stories and the other area
questions for sure let's go next to our
caller from the three six zero area code
who's calling today from three six oh hi
David this is Justin from yeah what's
going on hi
wondering about a stochastic terrorism
sure and how to bring that and talk to
to another radio audience I do a local
radio show here and I'm sometimes a
guest I wanted to start to bring this up
especially because of last week's
horrific domestic terrorism stuff okay
well I think that's a great idea what
what can I help you with on that um
mostly like information on how to deal
and debate with it you know I've been
slowly gathering research on a I know
you did your Maggie bomber one and just
maybe some resources point me in a good
direction to help talk about that and
then also debate it because I know I'm
gonna get pushed back from the mag agai
that's also on the program well I mean
so listen you the I think most of what
you want is is just you can google it
and you'll find a wealth of information
here's someone thought about preparation
the mag of people are going to make very
sort of superficial arguments about
legally speaking stochastic terrorism is
not really a thing like know what you
can't get in trouble for stochastic
terrorism and so you need to be prepared
to counteract that by say over time lots
of things have gone from being legal to
illegal and back and that's not really
the issue what you want to focus on is
the responsibility that people with
audiences should take seriously that if
they start going at someone and
targeting someone that it starts to
become statistically likely that they
are going to motivate someone in their
audience to go and commit an act of real
violence or whatever and don't let them
sort of corner you into these
discussions about it's just speech are
you trying to make their speech illegal
type of stuff don't try to avoid getting
cornered in that way okay thank you yeah
my pleasure good luck with that I hope
call back in let me know how it goes
okay great thank you thanks appreciate
it
let's go next to our caller from the
four one six area code who's calling
today from four one six
hey David can you hear me yes I can
hey David so I'm a big fan of your work
and I just start watching your channel
recently and I understand that you know
you're a progressive one and uh you know
I guess you shouldn't like dismiss
issues that relate to people's identity
so I I've noticed that a lot of your
videos about circumcision 1/2 like a
very high like to dislike ratio you mean
a very low like to dislike ratio so I
was always wondering have you ever done
like a like I don't know a u-turn on
your position on like non-medical
necessary circumcision on infant
children no I don't really talk about
her I mean circumcision is not a big
issue on my show well it's a big issue
in the United States and Canada where
it's being practiced more than it is in
Europe mm-hmm okay so I mean let's just
look at this way and you can argue that
granting the right to abortion for a
woman gives them more autonomy over
their body so why can't you apply that
logic to a infant male in or did you
apply it in the same way to vaccinations
well no because the reason one of the
reasons why I see circumcision is not
being medically necessary for babies is
because circumcision reduces like the
transmission of HIV and sex but a baby
child is not going to be engaging in
sexual intercourse so like see no reason
why it needs to be done right but I
think you would just you would agree
that an adult circumcision would be
crazy right like just as a matter of
course to just say we're gonna do them
all as adult circumcisions like that
you're not suggesting that right well
not what I'm suggesting is is that
circumcision
if they're for medical or religious
purposes they're done on people who can
consent to doing them not infant babies
especially not an infant babies for
religious purposes but would you apply
the same to vaccinations well no I
wouldn't because there's some
because abate as I said a baby's not
gonna have sex but a baby could kick a
baby could contract and the more measles
mumps and rubella and that affects them
attending school because we're not
vaccinating school Bennett but in any
case the bit in any case the bit I guess
I'm trying to understand
this is not a big issue for me but I'm
just thinking it through as you're
talking to me either way things are
being done to the baby that the baby
doesn't consent to right correct yeah so
then I guess the question becomes how do
we distinguish distinguish between those
things the latest I've seen from the
American Association for pediatrics is
that they say it's the parents choice
but the benefits outweigh the risks so I
guess it's sort of like where do we draw
the line right well we could just about
it I mean in Iceland they're talking
about banning it right now for babies
but why would you ban something that the
American Pediatrics Association says the
benefits outweigh the risks
the doctors one organization Ontario
you'll find plenty of organizations that
condemn circumcision and which
organizations should we listen to well I
mean I now I mean I'm pretty sure we can
no no I'm not saying let me rephrase I'm
not saying which organizations are you
thinking of I'm just saying what is the
barometer we should apply in order to
decide which organizations to listen to
if not the American pediatric
Association I think we should get a gen
for a general consensus from health
proxy nears across three years yeah
people doctors you know GPS who who are
against circumcision because one
organization condemning it I don't think
is enough justice to say oh well it's
kind of connector vaccine but isn't it
weird you just said we should we should
get the opinions of people who are
against it but it's like well we they're
against it so they're they're just gonna
be against it that doesn't seem like
those are the only people we want to be
talking to right well yeah of course we
can engage in comments of this course
it's gonna be people who are fur and
there's gonna be people for against it
I just wouldn't point to one
organization that says that the benefits
outweigh the negatives and again it's
not just the medical issue it's also a
moral issue because both a lot of
circumcision czar
performed for Medford not for religious
reasons I mean I'd say both a large
percentage of the men or males on this
planet are circumcised in the name of
religion I don't know that that's true I
mean I think I guess I need to look at
the well hold on a second I'd have to
look at the numbers but you know Jews
and Muslims are almost none of the
American population so most of the
American people being circumcised
they're just sort of like you know
putative ly Christian or or whatever and
I don't think that for them it's
religious and it's not being done as a
religious ceremony it's just being done
in a hospital right so I think I
questioned that assertion yeah but there
are seven billion people on this planet
I mean you only concerned about issues
in the United States or well we're
talking I thought I'm sorry you you
called and said you were talking about
the US and Canada no I said that I seen
previous video views previous videos of
you talking about circumcision on your
YouTube channel I don't think I
mentioned this specific region okay
yeah sorry you I thought we were talking
about the US and Canada all right well I
think I think you've made your point
well I mean I guess it's something maybe
you could reconsider I mean it's it is
primarily practiced in you know the Arab
world is practiced in in lots of Muslim
majority and you know the one single Jew
minority country so I mean I won't take
up the time for the rest of your callers
I'll just like that thank you
okay all right I will let that I will
let that sink in and see what that does
for me I know where you David thank you
time okay no it's my pleasure completely
let's go next to our caller from the
eight-30 area code hello yes hey David
my name is Jacobs and I got a very
hard-hitting important issue for you
here sure
so in light of the recent asan investing
breakup could you personally be grade
their personal issues sorry what who I
miss what you who broke up recently I
thought they broke up I didn't know they
were together okay yeah yeah and uh
could you
personally but grade their personal
issues for a strong front the leftist
politics could I do what grade their
personal issues you personally could you
could you personally be grade but grade
their personal issues book raid I've got
I don't know what that word means let me
look that up we're great okay I'm sorry
Brigade Brigade Brigade can i Brigade
them yeah could you per grade their
personal issues I don't know what that
wrong how do i brigade them could could
you i'll just rephrase it yes you settle
or moderate maybe some of their personal
issues i i would be glad to okay what
you're talking about it thank you all
right thank you very much appreciate it
okay let's go next to our call I'll do a
few let me see actually how much time I
have because things things are getting
crazy here at my house oh by the way I'm
just reminded of this because I just
looked out my window so I've been
growing vegetables in my yard here in
Boston urban urban gardening and there
are rabbits that have been stealing my
tomatoes I'm like you know can I have
the tomatoes or not are they just for
rabbits and so I built like a mesh cage
around my tomatoes and I caught the
rabbit just very upset looking at the
cage earlier today and maybe i'll stream
gardening but if you look at my
instagram and by the way you should
please follow me on instagram at david
pakman my latest pictures of the rabbit
just staring at the mesh cage and the
rabbit looks furious quite - quite
frankly let's go next to our caller from
the 72 four area code caller from 7:00
to 4:00 go ahead hello can you hear me
yes I can hey this is Alex I work as a
nurse
so I'm pretty into the health care
debate and one question I have about
medicare for all right it has to do with
the Bernie Sanders proposal and it's
about the implementation that goes I
think over three to five years four
years as this suspected implementation
and now my concern is that over this
period of implementation there would be
some people that receive a higher tax
rate to pay for it but don't receive the
benefits and are paying the premium and
in increased texture in this this isn't
very yes well in any proposed
medicare-for-all plan that has an
implementation where there's the tax
rates go up before the benefits start
okay yes you think about this it could
happen well I mean here in Massachusetts
there's a cyst there's a there's
actually something similar going on
right now where there is a paid
maternity maternity leave thing which I
believe you can't draw from until
January of 2021 but people will start
paying in like 0.7 percent of their
wages up to some minimal amount in a few
months and I don't think that that's
uncommon I think if you're talking about
more money like the couple percent that
the Bernie plan talks about I think you
do need to think about that because you
know a lot of people just can't afford
to be paying for their current private
insurance and pre-funding Medicare for
all so I think you probably need to have
some kind of transition that would not
require paying for it before you get the
benefits I see yeah and and that's
that's one of the things that concerns
me that you did do I have no time for
another point yeah that sure so there
was the exchange between Bernie and John
Delaney and the first debate that
happened where John Delaney was talking
about reimbursement rates right for
rural hospital and how they compare
between Medicare and private insurance
companies sure I think this and other
financial angles of Medicare for all
would be really great to explore in your
show and whether or not the research
pours out if you know these hospitals
can be funded with just Medicare at its
current rate I think that would be super
interesting yeah that's it that's a
really good idea all right okay thank
you for the call very much appreciate it
let's see what our caller from the 707
area code has to say
destiny and Andrew Yang and I'll
definitely have this very interesting
point about the trans-pacific
partnership and I'm not in favor of it
but he said about how listen well I I
did we had like an impromptu debate
about TPP on this stream like an hour
ago actually I just it's it's kind of
really but not really okay but I was
thinking it's more about Andrew yang
Valley at attack power could afford to
pay a thousand dollars month so every
American you know if we had those taxing
jobs in America and we also implemented
as value-added tax could it possibly be
enough money to subsidize the cost of
cars and phones because that wasn't his
biggest issue was like oh it with all
the cars and were amazed I hear it would
cost exponentially higher could I be a
possible thing it's possible but I I
hesitate I'm not really a big fan of
value-added taxes because they are very
regressive so I think that I would be
before even getting into the specific
question you're asking I would just be a
little hesitant because value-added
taxes are significantly regressive and
for that reason I'm not a big fan okay
thank you very much I won't take any
more of your time I'd say that question
thank you very much all right appreciate
it I have to save the caller is on these
Twitter streams are pretty good it's
like they get to the point for the most
part and I understand most of them which
is which is great let's go to our caller
from the eight one four area code who's
calling from eight one for today hello
yes hi I'm calling from Erie
Pennsylvania hey Tom my question for you
David is what do you think is the
biggest misconception that the general
public has about Medicare for all that
Bernie Sanders needs to do a better job
verifying or just needs to talk about
more I think it's just having really
workshopping the clearest possible way
to answer the question of wouldn't taxes
go up because oftentimes the way I've
seen him answer it is yes taxes will go
up
consider that you won't be paying
premiums and you won't be paying this
and you won't be paying that the whole
point is you're gonna pay less in total
and so the way I would answer it is
listen if I said to you you've got to
pay me two dollars but I'm gonna give
you back five what's the important thing
that you're paying me two dollars or
that you're netting three dollars back
because I returned five and something
like that to explain that you will pay a
payroll tax which will be smaller than
what you are paying for your private
insurance premiums and your co-pays and
coinsurance deductible etc etc it's just
like finding the right language to
explain that as clearly as possible oh
yeah I agree with you I mean I think in
my opinion I think the biggest
misconception that you know people like
john delaney they say you know I know my
father the union electrician loves his
you know private plan I mean I think you
know your average person doesn't really
like their plan I mean I think Kyle
kolinsky makes a good point about how
you know people are not going to choose
between weather no they want their plan
to cover you know a broken legs or you
know you know a ruptured spleen or
something maybe what people really care
about is you know being able to see the
doctor that they want going to the
hospital that they want right I think
that's a very fair point and and I think
that that's also on the list although I
think being super clear about the cost
is really important yeah you reek well I
think you're taking my call David
appreciate it yeah thank you for the
call please make sure particularly if
you're new to twitch to subscribe to my
channel with twitch prime which costs
you nothing okay if you have an Amazon
Prime subscription you can subscribe
with twitch prime to my channel costs
you nothing counts as a paid
subscription for us okay
connect your Amazon account to twitch
prime you hit that purple button
subscribe it's great CMV 970 subscribed
with twitch Prime in stay UNK subscribe
with twitch prime maple leaf socialist
subscribed at Tier one guy MN 999
subscribed with Prime
make good netcode sent me a hundred bits
which I appreciate
soda bada subscribed for one month at
Tier one which I much appreciate and dr.
Phil here subscribed with prime as well
it takes like 30 seconds to do and it's
it's really great for us so please do it
let's go to our caller from the five one
six area code who's calling today from
five one six hey David this is a Dan
from New York hey Dan so I know you said
you didn't see much of it but Bernie's
appearance on Joe Rogan has been mostly
positive from what I've seen right you
got something like over two million
views and under 17 hours or something
who knows how many download yeah but
I've seen some well-known like Twitter
warriors calling Bernie out because you
know Joe Rogan to them is somehow light
supremacist because he has people like
you know some right-wing people on his
show people like me yeah yeah so I know
you've said before like people like the
far-left or these social justice
warriors or auntie for more of a
distraction than anything yep but as a
progressive I'm kind of worried because
they were very loud minority and I feel
that they sort of push well-meaning
conservatives and even more moderate
liberals away from the progressive side
to be easily tricked by somebody like
Donald Trump when he was campaigning on
that I'm not you know your average
politician type of guy so my question to
you is as a you know true progressive
how do we make the distinction between
us and those like loud leftist people
who want to like stifle free speech and
you know ruin people's careers because
of a tweet from 20 years ago I mean
listen this is one of those things where
like we've got to draw a distinction
between our view and their view but you
don't want to just focus on it because
then it gives them more attention than
they deserve so I don't know that
there's any sort of like exact right
prescription for that it's just a matter
of like we fights that we fight bad
ideas and we fight the worst ideas even
more and we don't give any notion more
attention than it deserves it's like
okay there's some people who go too far
with identity politics but let's not
forget that identity is an important
thing in giving us perspective on issues
you just can't use it like a cudgel and
beat people over the head with it I
think it's just kind of like balance and
we have to respond in proportion to how
bad a problem is not more but also not
less okay well thanks for your opinion I
appreciate you taking my call
all right thank you appreciate the call
all right that's gonna do it for me
thanks to everybody who joined me please
subscribe with twitch prime subscribe
with twitch prime subscribe with real
money as well and make sure also to
subscribe on my website join pakman.com
streams will happen sporadically will
keep premiering our regular episodes on
twitch and if people have other ideas
for what I should be doing or whatever
if you want to be a moderator get in
touch using the website contact form on
david pakman.com